(woman announcing speaker)
(audience cheering)
- Hi.
- Woo!
- What up, Brisbane?
(audience cheering)
Sit, sit sit, let's do this.
- Let's do it!
- Brisbane!
(audience laughing)
Thank you so much for that
intro, super excited to be here.
It's been a long week, New
York to Oslo, to Copenhagen,
to Moscow, to LA, now here,
and I'm thrilled to be here,
Sydney tonight so a double
header for me, which is exciting.
First of all, I wanna thank you guys
for taking the time to be here.
There's a lot of things that I wanna cover
in our time together, and
then I also wanna really
focus on some Q&A at the end,
but really the couple things
that I wanna talk about
are mindset and tactics.
I think the things that
will really stand out,
and I have been following
along on social and Instagram
and watching all of you
tag, there's so much context
for what I talk about here,
I wanna make sure that
I don't go into places that
you guys are already used to
or you can watch on YouTube.
I wanna talk about things that have been
really emerging to me lately,
and the biggest one is mindset.
To me, the thing that has
really become fascinating,
the reason there's not a lot of content
that I put out between 2011
and 2014, if you go back
and look at the internet, is
because I needed to go run
and build VaynerMedia again for myself
because after writing Crush
It and speaking a little bit
from 2009 to 2011, I was starting
to get into a place where
people were talking about
me and calling me a speaker,
or a motivational speaker, or
an author, which is super fine
and an incredible thing to do, but for me,
my pride isn't being a practitioner,
and being an entrepreneur,
and being a CEO.
I needed to build another
hundred million dollar
plus business, really,
to be frank with you,
I need to feel comfortable standing here
and spitting my two cents on things.
I think that you need to have an execution
other than ideas to have the
audacity to stand up here
and expect people to
waste their time and money
listening to what you have to say,
and so I'm proud that
over the last six years,
I've been executing VaynerMedia,
and while I do this Gary
V thing, Gary Vaynerchuk,
the CEO of $150 million
holding company from scratch
is exciting and interesting, and it really
has become obvious to
me why that's happening,
and it's around mindset.
I think that there's way too
many people in this audience
that are in the excuse business.
I've, and yeah, it's tough
because I'm empathetic.
There's always things, you
know, you could have two parents
that were drug addicts, you
could have lost your parents
in a car accident when you were a kid,
you could have had your money
stolen to you by a partner.
There's so many things
that happen in life.
I'm super empathetic to it.
The ultimate problem is,
though, is that the market,
the world, doesn't care, right?
There's so much dwelling going
on, so many reasons why not,
and the thing that has been
really interesting to me
is that if you asked me what works for me,
it's optimism, and gratitude,
and positive mindset.
It's really interesting to
me, life is pretty binary.
It's either black or white,
it's either yes or no,
and the one that matters to me the most
is you're either on the
offense in your life right now,
or you're on the defense.
You're either coming up
with reasons why not,
all this technology, all
this stuff, the why not,
or why yes, all this
technology, all this stuff.
You're looking at things and
you're making a decision,
and so for me, a lot of what
I've been thinking about
is mindset and why optimism works.
Literally, seven minutes
ago, in the greenroom,
I'm on the phone with
executives of VaynerMedia,
I'm getting texts of a
scope that we expected
to sign failed, million
dollars, literally counting on
a million dollars, gone,
zero, not happening, right?
Another pitch, we were in
the final two $8 million,
didn't get it, literally in 47 seconds
back in the back room, I
lost $9 million. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
I'll be very frank with you,
I'm fuckin' pumped about it.
(audience laughing)
I genuinely like losing,
I like learning from it,
I was like thinking about
like why, what happened,
where'd we go, where was the misstep, why?
Like, it's really incredible,
look, when you can afford
to lose it, and I'm sure
people are thinking this,
it's easier, I get it, it's
not like I lost my million.
Vayner lost nine million
in revenue, but to me,
it's not about anything
other than mindset,
and so if I got anything out
of this, I'll go into tactics,
I'll talk to you about social in a minute.
I'm about to tell you why
Facebook and Instagram,
I did a lot of homework on Saturday
about the Australian market on
my theses around influencers,
Instagram, Facebook and Snapchat.
Let me save you a lot of time.
Everything that you've
been hearing me talk about.
How many people here consume my content?
Raise your hands.
- Woo yeah, woo!
- (laughing) Thank you, that was awesome.
(audience laughing)
Just gonna do that again,
how many people here consume my content?
- Yeah!
- Yeah. (laughing)
So, here's what's interesting,
literally everything
that I'm spitting comes,
obviously, from an American-centric
point of view, that's where I operate.
Obviously, we have a UK office,
we're looking at Singapore,
we're doing other things,
but I'm aware that
outside of Russia and Mainland
China, most of this stuff
actually works, maybe there's
a couple of different nuances,
what fascinates the shit out of me is
the consumption patterns of the Australian
and New Zealand market,
and the under-priced nature
extremities that I believe in, literally,
everything that I've been
talking about for the last year,
you can add an additional
20 to 40% tax of upside.
It is literally 20 to 40%
even better in this market,
and I get so pissed when
people are in any place
besides the US market or
China where they're like,
well it's a smaller market,
it's this, that, and the other,
that's where all the upside is.
You can only compete against
what you can compete against,
right, and so I believe
that we are living through
the greatest era to be
an entrepreneur, ever.
I think the internet is
grossly underestimated,
and I think there's a ton of
opportunity, but if you ask me
what I would wanna leave
with from this talk today,
it's to shift one or
two persons' mindsets.
To me, it's an incredible
feeling to stand up here
and expect nothing from nobody,
and take full responsibility
for everything.
The Teleco company that
gave it else and we lost it,
in the background, the eight million,
I spent zero days and zero seconds on it.
I was not part of the pitch,
I was not part of the process,
I empowered all my people, I
saw the news in the backroom,
and I took full 100%
blame in responsibility.
I am fascinated by your
upbringing, both your parents
and the neighborhood, and those
siblings, and the friends.
I am fascinated by your
upbringing, the era you grew up in,
the macro and micro climates
that you grew up in,
not the fucking weather,
I mean the economics
and the politics, and that climate.
I'm fascinated what
made me, my mom, my dad,
being an immigrant from
Russia, being in America,
being in Jersey, like
the friends I ran into,
baseball cards becoming popular,
allowing me to sell something.
I'm fascinated, the
environment that created me
in this completely emotional
place of enormous strength,
which is the engine and
the oxygen that allows me
to be successful in business and life,
and then what is it that
other people don't have,
or didn't have, and I see it.
I see how my grandmother parented my dad,
I see my sisters' and brothers'
DNA different than mine,
just timing and things
of that nature, and so,
I'm going heady for my opening spot
because I need you to
understand, too many of you
are gonna take fucking notes right now
and think it's about a Facebook ad.
Too many of you are about
to take a note and be like,
okay Google, how to use
Instagram influencers.
We'll get to that, I'm
about to talk about that,
but if your foundation isn't right,
you have no shot of long term success.
If you're not in a place where
you believe this, and look,
this is super, like, I'm
even throwing up on my,
to be very frank, here's
what's happening in my head.
I'm listening to what
I'm saying right now,
like this fuckin' sucks.
(audience laughing)
I'm being serious, I'm
being really fuckin' serious
with you, actually, and I'm
saying that because I'm like,
man, it's so hard, what I'm
talking about is like so hard
to touch, right, but it's still my truth,
it's what I believe, like,
you're either on the offense
or you're on the defense, you either see
all these technologies as the gateway drug
to your entire future, or you're upset
that it was much easier to
do this on email and SCO,
and you don't like this
social media thing, right?
I don't like these new things either.
I built my dad's business from a three
to a $60 million business
on email and Google AdWords.
I didn't want YouTube to come along.
I didn't want Twitter
to come along, right?
I didn't want Facebook to come along.
I didn't want Snapchat to come along.
I don't want Voice and Alexa Skills
and podcasts to come along.
I'm not looking forward to VR.
The problem is, technology,
and the way we live,
doesn't care about my
opinion or my feelings,
and it doesn't care about yours either,
and so you can walk around
Earth and judge, oh it's so sad
that all these kids can't communicate
'cause they're on the phone anymore,
or you can walk out
tonight and have dinner
and see people at a table,
and nobody's talking
to each other, and
they're all on the phone,
and you're judging, and
you could talk about
a day and age when it was
simpler and nicer and all this,
nobody gives a fuck,
(audience laughing)
and if you don't adjust to
the reality of the situation,
you will be completely
left behind, and that's it.
Too many people are executing,
or hoping, or trying
to figure out how to live
in a world that used to be,
or the way they wish it
was, versus attacking
the reality of the world, and here is
the reality of the world, my friends.
The cell phones that you're
all holding right now,
or in your pocket, are the
remote controls of our society.
They are the single most
important thing in the world,
there's nothing close,
literally, literally,
I would rather have somebody
roll up on me right now,
stab me with a knife and steal
my wallet than lose my phone.
(audience laughing)
The world is being lived
through that device, and you can judge it,
you can do anything you
want, but that's the reality,
and if you sit here today
and have any ambitions,
professionally, personally,
whether you wanna sell a course,
whether you wanna sell a
sneaker, whether you wanna
raise money for the PTA, a
non-profit, get somebody elected,
whatever you want to happen in life,
whatever you want to happen
in life, you first need
somebody's attention, and
then you need to tell them
about it, in the written
word, in audio or video.
This is how the world
works, and always has.
You want something to happen,
you need to figure out
where the people are to
tell them about that thing,
and then you need to communicate to them
in the compelling enough way that they do
the thing that you want them to do.
You can do that in the written word,
you can do that in audio,
and you can do that in video.
That is how it's been, it
was called the newspaper,
the television, and the radio.
Now it's called a blog,
a vlog, or a podcast.
It's the same thing, nothing's
changed except one thing:
your attention is moving to a new place
and leaving an old place.
The other thing is, we
have not figured out
the creative strategies to
be successful in this world.
The other thing is, there's
a lot of people in here
who are not self aware, and don't realize
they should only be writing,
and not making videos
'cause they're not good at it,
(audience laughing)
or reversed,
or reversed, there's
blanket statements that
everybody needs a personal brand,
or everybody should be doing video.
That is ludicrous, what
everybody should be doing
is deploying self awareness
and figuring out who they are,
quadruple downing on what
they're fucking good at,
and trying to get resources
to support the stuff they suck at.
I've written four, thank you.
(audience applauding)
I've written four, you
know when she was like,
"He's written four New York
Times best selling books,"
I literally was laughing as I was about
to get up the stairs,
I'm like, I can't put two
fucking sentences together
if my life depended on it,
but I know how to hire a ghost
writer, and I definitely know
how to sit down for nine hours
straight and record a book
in one fucking sitting, right?
You need to figure out how
you communicate to the world
as an executor, which
medium, some of you could do
all three, some can do two,
but watch what's been happening
over the last 10 years, or 15.
In 2002 to 4, it was the era
of the blog, it was bloggers.
How many people here were
a blogger from 2002 to 2005
at any point, raise your hands.
So, some of these early pioneers,
they felt the impact, right, right?
You were blogging, that was
it, that was the medium,
Word Press, or even going back further,
it was just a very important medium,
YouTube had yet to be
invented, it cost too much
to stream video online,
there was no video players.
Podcasting then came, in 2005
and 6, had a little blip,
but then right quickly after
that, Twitter came out,
YouTube came out, and everything shifted
to short form writing and video, right?
And then, the last two
years, audio has risen again.
How many people here
now listen to a podcast?
Raise your hands.
How many of those hands
did not listen to a podcast
three years ago, raise your hands.
Hold them up, actually you know what?
Watch this for visual, we're
gonna do this one more time.
How many people watched, how
many people are listening
to a podcast now, raise your hands?
I want people in the front to look around,
see what I see, alright?
An insane amount.
Now, of those people, of
the people that now listen
to a podcast, stand up if you did not
listen to a podcast three years ago.
I need you to look around,
because if you want to understand
why I'm standing on
this stage right now...
I didn't say sit down, I'm
just kidding, I'm kidding,
I'm kidding, kidding, kidding!
(audience laughing)
(laughing) If you want to
understand why I'm so blessed
to sit on this stage, is
I've a unique, uncanny,
I take no credit, my parents
get all the credit, ability
to slightly understand
what you're about to do
before you think you're gonna do it.
And so, what I do is when
I know something's coming,
I have humility, and this
is a word that I would love
for people to look up, understand,
and start really becoming religious about.
For all my ego and peacocking,
for the ones in here
who've been paying
attention, it is my humility
that has allowed me to be successful,
not in the way that I interact
with you and being kind,
'cause that's kindness,
in the humility that,
when I believe something new is emerging,
I take the perceived risk
of going there first,
spending countless hours with
no clear R-O-I in the short.
You know how many people here have left
ungodly amounts of money,
because when social came along
they said, well what's the
R-O-I of Facebook and Twitter?
Do you know how many people
here will lose the next frontier
because they're gonna
debate what the R-O-I is
of buying or building a
30,000 to 50,000 dollar
Alexis Skill or briefing
for their business, a lot.
People don't have the
humility to take the risk
of their time, and I'm
not even asking for money.
The fact that you didn't
have the humility to waste
three hours a day, even
though you had the audacity
to wanna be an entrepreneur
that lived on your own terms,
fascinates me, and I'm gonna repeat
that statement for all of you again.
The fact that you don't have the humility
to try the new stuff because
your time is so valuable,
yet, in parallel, you have the audacity
to want to live a life where
you don't work for anybody,
and you make your own, blows my mind.
Until I die, and I expect
to win the whole thing.
Until I die, I will
never deploy the audacity
of the situation that
I've asked for, which is,
I've asked for the loneliness
of being a number one.
I've asked to be able to choose my path
on an everyday basis.
I've asked to be an
entrepreneur, and I know that
you don't get to hang out
or rest on your laurels,
literally, literally,
everything I've done,
up until an hour ago,
is completely irrelevant
to where I'm going next,
and so many people get some,
a little level of success,
and start thinking they're somebody.
I looked at a couple
of you who tweeted me,
and like pumped, and
can't wait to see this,
and then I went and they're
hungry and they're gonna do it,
and they're bio says, I'm
gonna be this and that,
and then I look at your
Instagram, and you've got 11-,
14-, 23,000 followers,
and you haven't replied
to a single person that's
left a comment on a post
in the last year because
you think you're somebody.
And so, I believe that once
you get your mindset right
of accountability, empathy,
gratitude, humility,
that all of a sudden, what
I'm about to talk about next
makes a hell of a lot more
sense, which is the following.
My friends, if you do not spend 2018
completely and obsessively around Facebook
and Instagram, you will lose.
Let me say this, let me,
I'm making this very simple,
very black and white, very fuckin' basic,
if you do not spend next
year completely obsessing
over how you become successful
on Facebook and Instagram,
you will be disproportionately
less likely to win
because the ungodly amount of attention,
of regardless of where your consumer is,
regardless of the age, if
you use those two platforms,
you will cover the far majority
of what you're targeting.
If you're targeting under 20-year-olds,
then I'll start getting
a little more comfortable
with the disproportionate
Snapchat and Instagram audience,
but if you were targeting,
literally, 20 and above,
20 to 100, I don't wanna hear, guys,
the number one converter
for me on Facebook
across our clients, my
investments, and my audience,
are 50- to 80-year-olds on Facebook,
because there's something
called stream time,
and do you know what happens,
do you know the difference?
Here is a 29-year-old on Facebook.
(audience laughing)
Here's a 68-year-old.
Do you know the difference?
They consume the videos, and
the pictures, and the words
to a higher degree, and so,
I really need you to wrap
your head around the fact
that Facebook and Instagram
have ungodly attention,
that the ad product
on those two platforms are
disproportionately under-priced,
and that that is where
you should be trading,
not because I like Facebook or Instagram,
but because I wanna be
historically correct,
and I have one real micro-regret
in my business career.
Not passing on the Uber and
Angel rounds, not other things,
'cause those things are kinda come and go,
there's a lot of
variables that go into it.
No, the one time when I
knew what I was doing,
but I didn't go all in.
When I was building my dad's liquor store,
Google AdWords came out,
and I bought every wine term
for five cents a click,
and I owned every wine term
you could imagine for five
and ten cents a click,
form Australia Wine to
Barossa Valley, right,
to Penfolds Grange 1994, like every skew,
top, middle, like, understand?
I was getting customers
for 40 to 80 cents apiece
that were worth $10, $15 for
me, but I couldn't wrap my head
around how special that moment was.
I was young, right, I
didn't have experience,
I was just learning
about print, and outdoor,
and direct mail, it was
all working because of
the macro-product I created,
price-wise and selection-wise,
but I sit back, and when
I hear I built Dad's store
from three to 60 million,
and everyone's like yay,
I'm like fuck that guy,
that guy should've built it
from three to 250 million
if he was smart enough
to take his energy and
money away from print,
and radio, and television,
and direct mail,
and put it all into Google,
because Google had that moment
where it was grossly underpriced.
My friends, who was the biggest advertiser
on Google from 2002 to 2008?
Amazon.
Amazon was the number one
advertiser on that platform
in the early days, the
siphoned under-priced attention
to themselves, and now they've built
one of the biggest companies in the world.
Who's one of the biggest advertisers
in the last five years of Facebook?
A shopping app called Wish.
How many people here
are familiar with Wish?
Raise your hands, raise them high,
I want people to see this.
If I did this three years ago,
nobody would've raised their hands.
They are now a multi-billion
dollar retailer
that spent all of their
money, until recently,
now they're doing like the Mayweather
and McGregor fight
sponsorship, and the Lakers,
and they're doing, kind of branding stuff
because they've so penetrated
to billions of dollars on Facebook.
They were formal Google
engineers on the ad product,
quit making millions of
dollars a year, and started
a company selling stuff,
and only ran Facebook ads.
This, my friends, is
called pattern recognition.
I will do the same thing over and over,
I will be a 97-year-old Yoda looking dude,
standing up here, and
yelling at you about some
cockamanian thing, and it
will be the same exact thesis
that I'm spitting to you today.
Get your fuckin' mind right first,
so that you can then put
in the time and efforts
based on your ambitions in becoming
a humble practitioner
of where the attention
of the consumer is, and
if you have a moment,
like we have right now, on
Facebook and Instagram ads,
and Instagram influencers, you will win.
I spent four hours on the
flight DMing influencers
about my sneaker release and
my upcoming book release.
I did it, me, not my
intern, not somebody I hired
in the Philippines, my two fucking thumbs.
At this point, making tens of
millions of dollars a year,
because I have humility to
understand what needs to be done
to win, and everybody's
looking for scalability,
that I'm gonna hire my 23-year-old niece,
and she'll reply to somebody on Twitter,
and you completely downplay the reality
of what I'm talking about, you
are grossly underestimating
what's happening right now.
And, I say, by the way, I don't know you,
I'm talking about the market.
98% of people are grossly underestimating
how good it is right now, you
will look back at this talk,
all my content during this era.
Listen, how many people have heard me say,
"Watch what I'm doing,
not what I'm saying."
Raise your hands, good.
Usually, that refers to like,
what hashtags am I using,
why am I using Facebook,
why did I start a podcast?
Now, I'm gonna take it to the most macro.
Watch what I'm doing, not what I'm saying.
Why am I producing so much
content during this era?
Why am I flying around the
entire world over and over,
speaking to this subject?
It's because I know what
I'm talking about right now
is gonna go away.
I just want everybody to understand,
I'm making you a promise
of a micro-regret.
If you do not listen to me carefully,
and way more importantly, go
execute on it, you will regret
that you heard it in a passionate way,
and I think we can all
agree, I'm not hedging
up here right now.
(audience laughing)
I'm desperately trying to force this
down your fucking mouth, right?
You heard it, and I
believe that 95% of you
will not do anything
about it, I mean this.
I think that 95% of you
will do a little something,
you'll run a little bit
of ads, you'll do this,
you'll do a little something.
You'll do enough to make it
feel like you did something,
and you will regret not going all in.
How many people here play poker?
Good, I don't, but if you do,
when you have the best hand,
it's a good idea to go all in.
Right now, for the next 12
months, I feel comfortable,
maybe it'll last 18, the
biggest companies in the world
are not spending enough money
on Facebook and Instagram and SnapChat.
Let me explain, my friends,
what's going to happen
over the next three years.
When Coca-Cola, when
Budweiser, when Mercedes-Benz
finally gets their act together,
in the next 12 to 36
months, and take $30 million
that they would spend
on outdoor billboards
and sponsoring of the World
Cup and television commercials,
and they put it into
Facebook, and Instagram,
and influencers, you reaching
a 41-year-old mom of two
living in Hunter Valley,
who's interested in your shit,
today costs $4, $6, $7 CPMs,
$7 to reach 1,000 people.
When that costs 86 or 49, it shifts.
I know that everybody's
got different angles,
Facebook, and Instagram, and
Snapchat are marketplaces.
They're not, like, going
to the Sydney Daily News,
where they give you a
price that's a bottom.
They're marketplaces,
they start off at pennies,
and more people bid up,
the feed is only one feed,
everybody's trying to get
in, and if you wanna get in,
it costs more, and that's why
they become big businesses
because if they have the attention,
more people wanna get there,
but the price keeps going up.
The words that I spent
five cents a click for,
some of them are now $14 words.
Not as good of a conversion
as it was in 2003.
More importantly, you guys got
used to seeing Google's ads,
and you don't click them
as much as you used to
back in 2002 when you didn't know
if it was just organic
results or if it was an ad.
Today, Facebook and
Instagram and influencers
are under-priced, you're in
a feed, they're under-priced,
and you're still interested
in clicking those ads.
In four and a half years,
you're gonna be so tired
of seeing those ads in
Facebook and Instagram,
you're gonna click less,
and they're gonna cost
20 times more, understand?
That is basically all I wanna say.
I'm actually considering leaving,
but I think I'm obligated
to stay on the stage.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
How many people here
sell a physical product,
like a sandal, like a peanut butter?
Raise your hands.
Tonight, you go home, you
have an Instagram account
for that business,
raise your hands, great.
You go home, and you
DM every single person
using the hashtags that are
associated with your business,
and you direct message them,
and you ask them to send you
a sample of your product to
them, and would they post it.
Nine out of 10 won't even answer.
One out of 30 will post it.
The others will ask you to
give them money to post it.
You should pay them because
90 out of 100 of them
don't know how to price
themselves properly
for the attention that they're
giving you in return, right?
So influencer marketing, one
more time people with products?
Raise them high, and now
how many of those people
who sell products are selling
them direct to consumer?
Like, your own e-commerce
or things of that nature,
raise your hands.
Okay, listen, for the hundreds of you,
if you're not spending
90, 80, uh Google AdWords,
if you're not spending 65% of your money
on Facebook and Instagram ads,
and Instagram influencers,
you're leaving money on the table.
Blanket statement, without
knowing every detail,
blanket statement, if you're
not spending 65% of your money
on those environments, you're
leaving money on the table
because you have so much opportunity.
Now look, everything I'm
talking about is 100% right,
I know it, here's my only concern,
and I wanna spend a couple minutes on it.
The creative is the variable.
I'm right about the
thesis, but if the picture,
or the words, or the video
that you post to put in front
of each other sucks, you're
not gonna sell anything.
So, the reason this scares
me when I speak about
this subject to this kind of
audience, is I'm not in control
of the pictures, and the
videos, and the audio
that you're putting out,
but I implore you to try
a lot of different pieces
of pictures, and videos,
and written words, spend less
money on the ads upfront,
see what's working, and
then pour money on it.
Too many people in this audience
hear me, they get excited,
they go and Google how
to spend Facebook ads,
and by the way, all of you
have to do this yourself.
I don't care how fancy you are.
If you wanna be successful, you
need to be the practitioner,
not somebody in your office.
If you don't know what to
do, it's called Google.
Google, how do I place a Facebook ad?
Three hours later, you'll
place a Facebook ad.
It's not complicated.
Everyone says, but I
don't know how to do it.
Okay, it's fuckin' 2018, use
a search engine, you know.
(audience laughing)
So, the picture,
and the video, and the words
are the creative variable,
so please, please, please,
please do the following,
and this is where
everybody makes a mistake.
They hear this, they get
excited, they go and spend $5,000
trying to reach 25- to
30-year-old women in Australia,
and they just spend, it's
blanket, and they spend
on one picture and one
video, and it doesn't work.
Instead, what you need to do
is put 25- to 30-year-old women
in Australia, or in Sydney,
and make a reference
in your copy to ladies of Sydney.
You've gotta make it contextual, context
is the secret behind the
content that allows you
to be successful in this new environment.
Context, colors, we debate
the first three seconds
of the video, the headline,
the colors, the words.
The words are different
on Instagram than they are
on Facebook because, even
though you're the same person,
your mindset's different when
you're on your Instagam feed
and when you're on your Facebook feed.
The psychology behind
it, the network affect,
how to get people to tag
and refer their friends.
This is fucking science, my friends.
This is 2018 science,
social media marketing,
and by the way, there's no
such thing as social media.
It's a slang term for the
current state of the internet.
Social media marketing is the absolute
singular advantage in the marketplace.
Do I believe during a
big time sporting event
on television that a
commercial can be seen?
Of course.
Do I think it's still overpriced
for how many look at it?
Yes, because I know how many of you,
when it goes to commercial,
reach for your phone
and start engaging elsewhere.
All I will ever do is
chase your attention,
as it is now going from video to audio,
I'm triply downing on my
podcast, and on my Alexis Skills.
Watch this, you'll find this interesting.
How many people here...
How many people here
listen to my podcasts?
Let's start with that,
great, thank you very much.
Of those people, how many of
you have now started listening
more to the podcasts and watching
less video because of it?
Raise your hands, raise it
high, I need people to see this.
This is a significant number
of people who, in the last year
have started listening
more and watching less
because time is our number one asset,
and if you can hear me while
still doing something else,
the audio's more valuable
than watching the video,
which you have to watch as
a medium, so if you do not
have an audio strategy for your business,
if you have not started
creating the podcasts
or really leaping to the
strategy behind building
an Alexis Skill for your
business, you are leaving
an enormous amount of
opportunity on the table.
Please, please, please start
getting your audio strategy.
You guys are runners for the mics?
Yeah, alright, I'm gonna
use one more minute,
and then I wanna start thinking about
raising your hand for a question.
My friends, listen, how many people here
are good at cooking, raise your hands.
Raise 'em, it's a pretty audacious bunch.
(audience laughing)
I couldn't even begin
to think about cooking, right,
it's not a skillset I have.
For so many of you, it just
came natural from the beginning.
Being an entrepreneur, more importantly,
being a successful entrepreneur,
is a skillset, and it's one
that comes natural to some,
and others not as much.
It's a fun thing to be right
now, and everybody wants to,
and the opportunity is very real.
I'm a great entrepreneur,
but I think I'm even better
at consumer behavior and psychology.
It's who I am, that's why
a lot of you follow me
because when you cut me down, you see that
I'm pushing positivity, and
a whole lot of other things
that matter, and trying
to get people to do it
the right way, be patient, do
the right thing, da-da-da-da.
My friends, you need to get yourself
in the right place
mentally, and then you need
to get yourself in the
right place mentally
because the thing that
people have not wrapped
their head around is that
this takes a lot of work,
like a lot a lot, not a little something,
and if you aspire, let
me just ground this.
If you think you're gonna
make a million dollars a year,
which is funny the way
people throw that out,
like everybody gets there,
almost nobody gets there, right?
If you wanna make $500,000 a year,
which would put you in
the disproportioned top 1%
of income getters here in Australia.
If you wanna make $100,000
a year and like doing it,
and it's on your terms,
and it's your life,
it takes a lot of work, and
it takes a lot of smart work.
The thing I talk a whole
lot about is hussle.
The thing I talk less about is being smart
because I don't think
that brings you any value.
So, what I do is I try to
come and speak, or through
my actions, show you the
smart things that I'm doing,
and then remind you that
it's still hard work.
The framework is simple, this is simple,
you may have not allowed yourself to have
the honest conversation with
yourself of how much hard work
and how much patience it
takes to be successful,
but it doesn't change the
fact that that's the case.
You've never met anybody in your life
who hasn't worked their
face off for a long time
that's built something significant.
It may seem that it happened
fast 'cause they're 27,
but maybe they've been
hustling since they were 13
in a different way that gave
them 14 years of experience
to be a winner in that
game, and so, please,
please wrap your head around
what we're actually doing here,
and more importantly,
if you were smart enough
to be here today, and I mean this,
the fact that you came here today
puts you so far ahead of everybody else,
and I hate knowing for
fact that so many of you
are gonna give up your
advantage because you like
hearing me say it, and
you like the way it feels,
but then you leave and you
don't do anything about it.
So, please, Brisbane, do me a favor,
go do something about this talk today.
I implore you, it will change
the course of your career.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
Thank you, questions?
You can pick anybody, let's go.
Great, how are you.
- Gary, what's up, man?
- Real good.
- You talk a lot about,
saying that Facebook and
Instagram, and all these places
that you're putting a lot
of time and money into now
for advertising is gonna come to an end.
What spaces, or what
businesses are you watching
to see what's gonna come next?
- So in general, I like
to tell people, look,
I'm not fuckin' Nostradamus, right?
So, I've no idea, the one place
I keep looking at is Voice.
I keep telling you guys, guys, Voice.
Everybody in this room, in five years,
will have voice activated
devices, whether it's their phone,
their clothes, their car,
the wallpaper in their home,
that instead of grabbing a
phone, you're gonna interact
with Voice, it's going to be frictionless.
You've gotta figure out how
your business and service
interact in a Voice environment,
it's going to be Voice.
So, the first thing you should all do
is start a podcast, if you think you can.
Podcasts are great because you
could just interview people,
even if you're not that
interesting or don't know
what to say, you could just
interview people in the industry
or genre that you're in, and you just ask
nine questions and boom, you're done.
There's an app, I'm not an investor,
and everybody thinks I am, but I'm not,
called Anchor, which
is a voice social app,
you should look it up, it's called Anchor,
where you can record it
on that, hit one button,
and it posts to all the podcast platforms.
It's just so simple, it's the first way
to get into Voice, but bro,
let me tell you something,
Facebook and Instagram are going nowhere
for the next 24 months.
I can't get people here to
spend enough time on that,
let alone worried about what's next.
Until you're fuckin'
spending all your money
and all your time on
Facebook and Instagram,
I have no energy to
talk about what's next.
You're fuckin' up what's now.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
- Thanks, man.
- Thank you.
Red shirts, you're in charge,
let's go, let's move quick.
- Hi, what's up Gary?
My name's Christian, I just
like, I own a business,
so I do a nightclub in Brisbane,
I do that, and I also got
a personal brand as well,
Hype MC for nightclubs,
but what I'm stuck on, I was
just, about four months ago,
I started another
business printing shirts,
and I'm still in between,
should I cross-brand
or use the Shay's logo
as the printing thing
and the nightclub thing,
what do you suggest?
- It doesn't matter.
- Thanks, Scottie.
- I mean, I mean, I'm
being frank with you.
People overthink shit that doesn't matter.
It's not gonna matter if you
use one logo or separate logos.
Like, it doesn't matter where I use Vayner
and where I don't, when I'm library
or Gary V or Vayner, it doesn't matter.
I love when people wanna talk to me
about the name of their business.
Nobody cares, nobody
knew what Google meant,
or Facebook meant, or
McDonald's meant, or Coke meant.
A name doesn't matter, what
you do to make a name matter
is what matters, right, so
nobody gives a shit, bro.
Just pick one and fuckin' go.
(audience laughing)
- [Man] So it's just all about
branding branding, basically?
- Yeah, it's about the execution, right?
Like, it didn't matter
if he called himself,
you're wearing a shirt of a guy
who called himself multiple things.
He was the Notorious B.I.G.,
and Biggie Smalls (laughing),
and plenty of, like, it doesn't matter.
Execution, people wanna
debate these things
because they think that's
the unlock, it's not.
Period.
- Yeah.
This is actually one of
the shirts that I printed,
by the way, just putting it out there.
- I figured.
(audience laughing)
Alright, let's move, let's go.
Red shirts, let's go, give me.
- Gary, Steve.
- Let's get some people
in the back.
- At the end of
your audiobook, Ask Gary
V, you said something
that hit me in the face
in a good way that you
never met your granddad or
something, and that played a part
in the way that you document.
- Yes.
- Curious to know, how much
does that still play a part
in your day-to-day decisions,
and why do so few people really get that?
I never got to meet my granddads
either and I was like shit,
it really affects me,
so that's my question.
- I think so few people think,
I don't think people
understand, I think people think
I just talk, like in 50
years, they'll understand
that I meant it, like,
I care about my legacy.
That's why I think about it.
Like, I only care about my legacy.
When I made $100,000 a year,
I achieved my only financial
goal that I ever had.
Somewhere around 13, I was
like, it'd be really cool
to make 100,000, like, when
you're coming form humble,
that seemed big, you know, so that was it.
Why, because I've always felt something
in the middle of my stomach
that I had something.
I care about my legacy.
I love that my great,
great, great grandchildren
are literally watching this right now.
I'm long-gone, but they're
watching this, hey Jeremiah,
you know, and so.
(audience laughing)
I mean, that's cool, I
think it's super neat.
Like, I think I have a lot
to give, I think I've impact,
how many people here think,
and don't make me feel good,
how many people here truly
think that I've impacted them
in a positive way?
- Yeah!
- I mean, look at that, and so like,
but I'm not gonna be able to do that
for my great, great
grandkids, but now I am,
'cause if I can do it to you,
I can definitely do it to them
'cause they're gonna watch everything.
Imagine there was film like this, imagine,
how many people watch Daily V?
Thank you, could you imagine if Daily V
was about your great, great grandmother?
You know how fun that would be?
If you're like, oh shit, I
do that same thing that she.
It's so cool, watching my
daughter do things that I do,
thinking how those get passed
on, it's gonna be neat,
plus my man, do you know
why I obsess over my legacy?
Do you know why I document everything?
'Cause I know I'm good, and
when you know you're good,
both in your skill and in your heart,
you're not scared of the camera.
And so, it matters to me
because I care about my legacy,
not about the short term money.
Everybody's so worried about tomorrow
that it doesn't allow them to see
what's actually happening
here, and that's why
I always recommend people spending time
with older people, retirement home.
I'm a big fan because you get
to see regret and resentment
up close, and it starts
to help you frame up life,
and I did something very weird.
I don't talk about this a lot publicly,
and you guys know a lot about
me, I spent so much time
with old people when I was
little, like from five to 13,
if I went to a playground
and there was like
a grandfather visiting, or a grandmother,
it wasn't just a grandfather
thing, I would literally
stop playing and go sit with
them and sit on the bench
and just ask them random questions.
I was a weird ass kid,
(audience laughing)
but it makes a lot of sense to me now
because I'm way more wisdom oriented than,
like my energy acts, my
energy's so micro-fast
and intense, and alpha
male and competitive,
but when you start peeling
away, it's very obvious
why it matters to me,
I'm only about my legacy.
I'm only about what everybody
here says behind my back.
- Thanks.
- You got it.
(audience applauding)
Let's do it.
Who do we have?
Hey.
- Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- My name's Jordan.
Good, thanks, so I'm a little torn,
I've read into your content
for about eight months,
- Thank you.
- And I've really struggled
to launch my business.
- Okay.
- [Jordan] Self awareness
was a big part of that.
I started a life coaching
thing a while ago,
and never really felt connected to it.
My history's one of drug
addiction and car accidents
and time in prison, and so
I go around to youth centers
and high schools and I talk for free,
and that's actually what I love to do.
- I love it.
- But, I've never found a way
to brand myself or make
money because I feel like
part of me's got a shame thing around it.
- I understand.
- Where the family
and the people involved that
were hurt in my accident,
so I don't even know why
I got up to talk, but,
(audience laughing)
listening to your Facebook
strategy, I think I wanna
make some videos, but I wanna
be really sensitive around--
- Well, let's actually have
this conversation for a second,
and I appreciate you standing up.
Are you still in a place where you wanna
protect the other, the ashamed part?
I feel very comfortable that
you've just brought it up,
so you are in a place where
you, listen, it's your truth,
you're on to the next chapter.
Is there still reasons
to hold it, to the best,
because it can affect
others, or are you still in
the last stages of being okay
with putting it out there?
- [Jordan] I'm not sure,
so I crashed a car in '09.
One of my passengers
died, part of the accrue,
I was heavily drunk and on
drugs, and I've never really
been able to connect
with the family involved.
Obviously they have their
reasons, so I don't know
whether I'm gonna stir
something up with them
by writing a book, and people tell me--
- I get it, first of all, I
adore you for that answer.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks.
- And, the best part is,
it allows me to give you
a really good piece of advice.
People are confused,
intent is an incredibly
important part of all this.
The reason I'm so out
there and so the way I am
is 'cause I know what my intent is.
You may not like it at first.
You may think I'm cocky and a
douchebag, I'm cool with that,
'cause I'm gonna win in the end.
I prefer you all started out not liking me
because it's more fun
the other way, right?
So, brother, the fact
that you have that intent,
I'm gonna really try to
force you to do this.
You should reach out to
them, call, go ahead.
- I wrote a letter.
- What's that?
- Great.
- [Jordan] Years ago,
telling them how I felt.
It wasn't well received.
- Sure, respect.
Do you think they're on Facebook?
- [Jordan] Um, I've blocked
them 'cause when I got out
of prison, I got sent
some unkind messages,
so it wasn't nice so
I blocked them to just
move on with my life.
- I respect that,
how long ago was that?
- When did I get out?
2014.
- So look, listen.
If you wanna, listen, there's
only one way to move forward.
It's reconcile the past, right?
So, you need to do everything you can,
and listen, you could still talk about
your past without mentioning names.
For a long time, if
anybody's watching carefully,
up until about six months
ago, I never really
made it as clear that I own
nothing of Wine Library.
Only until about six months
ago, as my popularity
has exploded in the last year,
a lot of people are saying,
well, you can't listen to
him because his dad gave him
a $4 million business, and I
needed to eliminate that excuse
for the kids that wanted to listen,
so I started talking about something
I wasn't comfortable
with, which was, you know,
talking about me building
such a big business
and owning none of it, I was worried,
could shed negative light
on my dad, to be very frank,
and I wasn't comfortable talking about it.
So, I've gone 10 years being in public
without ever really clarifying it.
I've only started clarifying
it now because I don't think
it sheds bad light on my
dad, family businesses,
everybody knows it, and more importantly,
I have to eliminate that
excuse from the Lexicon
so that people realized
what my journey actually is
so they can work hard, 'cause
god, people are really looking
for the excuse to not work hard.
(audience laughing)
And so, anyway brother,
you can tell your narrative
and put it out there
without referencing the family.
Sure, they could Google
it and figure it out,
but as long as your intent is right,
you need to start recording those talks
that you're doing for free,
putting them on Facebook.
I have good news, it's gonna work out.
(audience applauding in agreement)
- Thanks so much.
- You got it.
Let's go back there, if we can.
- Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- [Man] Very good.
Now, just as like a practical question,
when you're talking about
Instagram and Facebook
and everything.
- Let's be practical.
- [Man] I think for everybody,
put some numbers on it,
so say a business owner
here that had $50,000 a year
to spend on ads, what
percentage would you recommend--
- If we're gonna go--
- Real general, you know?
- Look, yeah, I mean, that's the problem,
what kind of business, right?
It it's B to B, I'd, with only $50,000,
I'd go LinkedIn and Facebook, right?
If it's selling t-shirts
to people under 40,
I would be 80% Facebook and Instagram
with a little bit of Google AdWords,
some people that are typing in an intent.
- [Man] Of all the people
that have never used Facebook,
Instagram, and digital media
before, what would you say
is a really good place for
them to start, as far as
percentage-wise, so you got,
like, two grand per month
into that, two grand into
that, one grand into that?
- You're not gonna achieve
what you're trying to do here,
and I love it, you're
doing the right thing.
The problem is, it's super
nuanced, but the reality is that,
like I said earlier, they've
gotta spend money on it.
How many people here
already, besides Facebook
and Instagram, spend over
$10,000 a month in marketing?
Raise your hands, raise them
high, so not a lot, right?
How many people here spend
$3,000 a month in marketing?
Raise your hands, right,
how many people here
don't spend any money in marketing?
Raise your hands, right, so
you've got a lot of differences.
What's amazing about all
this is, no matter where
those hands went up, more
than 50% of their energy
should be on Facebook and
Instagram, that's enough to start.
Energy, which means either
organic engagement and creative,
'cause you have no fuckin'
money, or that percentage
of your money, go Google and learn,
test and learn, test and learn.
- Yep, alright, thanks.
- Cheers.
Let's get the, can we
get, red shirts, sir.
Yeah, can you go all the way back there?
Good, hello.
How are you?
- Hello, my name's Robyn.
I'm an exercise physiologist
and I run a private practice.
- Awesome.
- Working the health industry,
it's a little bit harder to
kind of push people to come
and see you, 'cause ultimately,
at the end of the day,
I want people to come see
me if they need my help.
Do you have any advice for standing out
on those social media platforms?
- Well look, it doesn't,
you have to understand this,
your dynamic doesn't change
if you advertise on Facebook
or Instagram, or if you
advertise in the print, or if,
you know like, they're all
the same dynamics, right?
So, are you getting most of
your customers from referrals
and other dynamics, or how
are you getting them now?
- [Robyn] Mostly Allied
Health NGP referrals.
- Right, so now you're
looking for more upside
because you've got a B to B dynamic
that's driving to your business, right?
I would just put out tremendous content,
that is the best advice you
have for the general pub,
look what I do, I give
away all my stuff for,
my best advice for, do you know how many,
do you know how many advertising
and social media agencies
have been built on the
back of my free content,
that are doing one to three
million dollars a year?
(all laughing)
Right?
Like, just left and right,
and it makes me happy.
It makes me happy that
something I'm doing for free
is helping others because I don't think
it's coming out of my pocket.
That's where everybody gets confused.
People get confused 'cause you think
when you're doing something
good, it comes at your expense.
It doesn't, there's so much out there.
I'm never gonna get to all of it.
I'd much rather have your
admiration or love towards me
because I helped you, so you
should just be putting out
your best advice, especially
'cause all you're getting
your business form B to B to begin with,
and then that will create halo
effects for the entire brand
because right now, your in
transactional sales funnel
on the backend, you need to create brand.
My advice to, yeah, there's
a good way to stand out.
Give away the best advice
you have, forever, for free,
for as long as you possibly can.
- [Robyn] That's fantastic,
awesome, thank you.
- You got it.
(audience applauding)
- Good day.
- Go ahead.
- [Liam] Well Gary, Liam's my name.
Love your work, you're the king, mate.
(audience laughing)
I work for a
big insurance company, it's not my brand.
I'm not an entrepreneur, I think
I've sorta worked that out.
- I respect that.
- But, I really wanna
connect with a lot or people,
I wanna sort of be, I guess,
looked as an influence a day on the track
amongst my sort of industry.
I'm just sort of having a
bit of trouble struggling
to sorta get that going--
- Why?
- [Liam] Well, I just,
I guess, try to work out
different ways to get out there and do it.
I work in sales, I don't
actually sell our product myself.
I help people sell it amongst their work.
- So, you're in a B to B environment
where you're training others,
or helping others to do that.
- That's right.
- So, why is that a struggle?
What's in the air that makes
it tough for you to put out
words, audio, or videos
on Facebook and LinkedIn?
- [Liam] I just try to get
the legwork going, I suppose,
in the first instance.
- What's the fuckin' problem?
(audience laughing)
- Well, I guess, uh...
(all laughing)
- Can I ask you a question?
- [Liam] I really wanted to
ask a question, and it was
a two part, the second was,
can I get a selfie with you?
That was pretty much--
- Now we got to the punchline!
(audience laughing)
Yeah, you can, come on.
(audience applauding)
'Cause that first part sucked.
Alright, let's keep it
going, who's got the mics?
We'll come back up front in
a second, go ahead, mate.
- Hey Gary, I just
wanted to say thank you.
You got me off the bench.
- I'm listening.
- [Man] I was out of
the game, I was nowhere,
I was kinda dead, and
you always talk about
deathbed regrets, and I just started,
I'm just learning mechanics.
Like, I've always seen
the class, but you made me
love the dirt.
- Good.
- [Man] And man, I've
got mad love for you.
I just wanted to say thank
you because on my deathbed,
(sighing) I'll be a happy man.
(audience applauding)
- Means a lot to me.
- [Man] Now, the question
I wanna ask, sorry if I
screw it up 'cause I'm a little
bit nervous, I'm a teacher.
I know the story of
little Gary really well,
and one thing I've said
on Twitter before is that
if little Gary, in English class,
could of written copy instead
of handwriting lessons,
he would've got an A instead of a D.
What I do in classrooms
is take self development
and peak performance culture.
- I love it.
- [Man] Yesterday in a
classroom with a little girl,
she likes horse riding,
and I pulled out Audible,
and I pulled out Crush It,
and I showed this little girl
Crush It, (sighing) now,
my question is this.
I'm a teacher, I rely on
teaching for my income.
- I understand.
- I'm at that
sort of difficult stage.
- Yes.
- [Man] Tactics, when I'm in
that world, because some of
the people in the teaching world
are, to be perfectly frank,
pretty fucking dull and
not particularly inspired.
How do I either agitate
from within that world,
and there's risks in that involved, to me,
'cause technically you're not
supposed to have a business
inside that world.
- You know what's crazy?
It's a similar thesis to Clouds and Dirt.
You're not gonna win that game, my friend.
So, what you need to do is deal with that,
be Clark Kent, and then
be Superman after hours.
You're gonna have to find a
different place to scratch
to achieve that because
the framework of schooling
and university in the globe today
will not allow you to
do what you wanna do.
You're gonna be half
pregnant the whole time.
(audience laughing)
I'd rather you just
become numb to that,
play within the margins,
take it all as upside,
right, 'cause you're gonna be
half pregnant, take the
upside of what you're doing
in the class as all gravy,
instead of half empty,
and then spend all your
energy post-game in a place
that doesn't get you fired,
and you don't shit on it,
you just create another
environment where you can scratch
even more of that itch 'cause
you're not gonna win that game
and you need to wrap your head
around that, and that's okay.
I'm eating shit right now,
VaynerMedia is to what I wanna do
for a living, I don't wanna have clients.
I don't wanna be back
there and somebody made
a subjective call, it's
just that I'm eating shit,
half pregnant, to build
a framework, so then
when I buy brands, I will
dominate and do what I wanna do,
but I'm right now deploying
the most patience of my career,
at the height of my Gary
V-ness, where I could be
25 to 50 million dollars
a year, just being me
and getting admiration, I'm
eating shit, and having clients,
and dealing with operations because I know
what I want to achieve on my deathbed.
You should do the same, but you
need to reconcile that truth
instead of being romantic
that you're gonna be
the one person that changes
the fuckin' education system.
(audience laughing and applauding)
- Thank you.
- You got it.
Let's get up here for this
lady right here at some point.
- Gary, hi, sorry about that.
- No worries.
- [Man] Gary, I just
wanna ask you a question.
The start of your talk,
you talked about family.
Gary, my grandfather was head of security
for Hitler's Eagle's Nest,
he married a Jewish woman.
My father is one of the worst
pedophiles in this state
in the last 10 years,
he bashed me every day,
I've been through a lot in my life,
it's a bit of a miracle that I'm here.
I do run business, I do
have great wins and also,
I guess, great losses, I
wanna know, you mentioned
just before you came on the
stage, how you could handle
a nine million dollar loss.
I'm just curious, like, I find
that anytime I have a loss,
I sort of go back into things
that have happened in my life.
I have no family, my
mother's family's completely
out of my life, everything
I have I've made of myself.
So, I was wondering how a person
handles losses.
- I respect that, so look,
that nine million dollar
loss is gonna hurt a lot less
than when I read Twitter on the
way to the airport right now
and somebody who was brought
as a friend was like,
"Eh, too brash for me, I don't like him."
Like, you know, so they
come in all, it's not about,
the losses come in all shapes and sizes.
Look man, I'll be honest
with you. (laughing)
You're like a hero, I don't
know what your, you know like...
(audience applauding)
I mean, I don't. (laughing)
You were talking, and
I was like, fuck man,
I wish that was my background.
(audience laughing)
I'm being dead serious,
I'm being dead serious.
Now, you might say, oh easy
for you to say if you lived it.
Look, everybody has good and bad.
In life, we're all born
with either an advantage
or disadvantage, we either
started with too much,
or we started with too
little, and then basically,
your internal fortitude decides
if that was good or bad.
I've sat with people that have $10 million
in their trust fund crying, saying
that they hate their lives
because their parents
took care of everything and
they'll never achieve anything
on their own, and no
matter what they achieve,
everybody's gonna say it wasn't them,
and they think it's the
worse, and they're suicidal.
This is real, now for somebody
like you, or others that
started with zero, you're
like get the fuck out of here!
(audience laughing)
10 million, you know?
Listen man, to be very honest with you,
I'll give you the answer,
you have no choice.
That's how, what's the alternative?
When you have a setback, are you gonna say
it was your granddad and your dad?
I mean, you know that's
not true, it's why you have
so many wins, right, so just practice.
I just kept practicing
blaming myself for everything.
Now I just default into it.
I genuinely believe
everything's, but I think
it's drizzling here because of me.
(audience laughing)
Like, I think,
I think you just have no choice, brother.
- Thanks, Gary.
- You got it.
Can you do me a favor, 'cause
I'm running outta time?
Can we get this lady right here?
Nice Vayner sports shirt in
the front row, I like that.
- [Woman] Thank you,
you're amazing, I just have
to pace 'cause I'm intensely nervous.
First thing, I'm gonna
update my Facebook profile
to say that Gary
Vanderchuk called me lady.
(all laughing)
Sorry, I just have
two things to say, the first
one is, almost five years ago
I was left when I was pregnant.
My baby was diagnosed at
birth with down syndrome.
I had to quit my corporate
job, and I finally went back,
I'm not gonna cry, I cried in Pat Flynn.
Some of you guys were there, you saw it.
I'm not gonna cry for Gary
V 'cause you're my internet
spirit animal.
(all laughing)
So, I went back to my
job at the Australian
Taxation Office, and I was
their Facebook channel expert,
and sorry if any of them say this, but
I watched your podcast on one screen while
I increased their following
by 25% while I was there.
I then quit my job and launched a course,
which was five months ago,
I launched my first company,
thanks to you, and also
Pat Flynn, but mostly you,
and I, we turned over
$275,000 in course hours,
and I've now been able
to recurring income,
and I did that by
reaching out, giving back,
and building my community generously.
In the meantime, I've
built up my son's Facebook
and Instagram profiles with your help.
My son won Baby Buns, which
is Australia's biggest
modeling competition, he
was in the Oscar Gift Bags
last year, he's a beautiful little boy,
and we're having a selfie,
I'm so nervous! (laughing)
So, I'll show you his photo.
A few months ago, I nagged
DownSyndromeAwareness.com.
What can I do to build his profile?
'Cause likes don't pay for his mortgage.
- So, one more time, you're
asking how to continue
building his profile?
- Yeah,
so I can build this out really
successfully for myself,
but it's for my little boy.
He's got 24,500 Facebook
followers, I create resources,
I've got a website I've
built called ParkerMiles.com,
we've done Mannor 3045,
I've got Batlinks in Yahoo,
his videos get picked up by
Jukin and I can't monetize him.
I just am so resistant,
I don't know what to do.
- I don't think you need to monetize him.
- [Woman] Okay, good 'cause
everyone tells me I should,
and I just feel like, what do I do?
Like, do I need to, 'cause I
just wanna grow his community.
- Can I just talk about it?
When you sit down, make
the list of the people
that told you you should monetize it,
and then put me on the
other side of the list.
- [Woman] Okay, 'cause they
make less money than me
and you make more, so--
- It's just, you know,
it's not even about, honestly, I swear,
it's not about making more,
it's about moral compass,
it's about legacy, it is about,
currency is part of the equation.
The thought that you have to
monetize that is ludicrous.
- Thank you.
- What you should do
is continue to monetize what you're doing,
be super successful, and
you'll have more than enough,
and you won't be spending
the energy debating
monetizing that side of it.
- Yep, I think I just
needed to hear that because
the reason I go to that
is because community's everything
and intent is everything,
and I just feel like it
never really resonated,
so I couldn't stock things
or do this stuff, or--
- Listen, I'll leave you guys with this.
Doing anything that doesn't ring true
down your entire
operating system and soul,
because you think you
need to do it based on
somebody's advice that you
admire, or because you have
short term pain in your
life, is never going to work.
It has never worked, it doesn't
work, and it's just better
to wrap your head around
enjoying the short term pain,
and I mean that, like,
listen, the Rocky movies
that are good is when it's shitty,
not when he's in the fancy mansion.
Like, that gentleman's background, yours.
Everybody has diversity, has adversity,
and more importantly, if
we put everybody's stories
on a table here, right,
that gentleman's story's
pretty intense, he's
probably be very high up
in the adversity, but here's the problem.
If you're sitting with
some adversity right now,
it's yours, right?
No matter what your adversity is,
just having a mom that wasn't supportive,
just so you all know, is pretty hardcore.
Having a non-supporting
mom is a unbelievably
difficult thing for the
majority of human beings.
So like, we all have it.
- I think I'm already getting,
- Go ahead.
- I think I'm already getting
my return on investment because
I get messages all the time
from moms whose nurses have
referred them to my page
and they're crying for--
- Of course.
You knew the answer, you just
needed to hear it, thank you.
- [Woman] Thank you, so
I'm gonna write a book.
(audience applauding)
- Brisbane, I gotta go.
I gotta get to Sydney,
I love you, I'm sorry.
I've got nothing but love
for you, thank you so much
for coming, see ya.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
(inspiring music)